you will be in room 237
and you have free wi-fi there also from
6am to 10am
every morning there's a free continental
breakfast
continental breakfast yes from 6am to
10am
so it's continental then
very good
like garcon a one
uh admission for the continental
breakfast
you can just help yourself sir oh
interesting
european style
[Music]
when in rome
the forbidden fruit
oh well aren't you a tiny plum
[Music]
well la dee
vapor and everything and who are
you my little friend not a spoon
not a fork but something in between
a fapoon
what will you think of next germany
[Music]
all the european countries lay before me
where should i fly to first
the pit of the donut mmm
thank you turkey mmm buckle up
let's see where we shall go next ah the
danish
clearly from brussels um
hello grease where the yogurt flows like
water
yes like go good but to stay
so good pulling into spain
baked to perfection can you believe this
it all comes with the room mm-hmm
i love being incontinent i love being in
congress
i delight to the senses isn't it my
friend
isn't it yes
i have what i'm having
what i'm
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's having good